all right it's always nice to end the
hour with something that brings a little
Joy I feel like this whole episode has
brought some Joy but whatever this is
what I'm
[Music]
liking usually when someone graduates
from college there's a lot of family
Fanfare and celebration but when Texas
grad Ashley got her degree there was
even more for the family to celebrate
both her mom and dad got their degrees
as well at the same University on the
same day which is so cool it Mar of
first in Texas Lutheran University's
history we have all these degree holders
on the line right now watching on W AI
in Texas say hi to Ashley and her mama
and daddy Robin and Greg
everybody hi
y'all I mean I guess I'll start with you
Greg like what first of all thank you
for your service you were in the
military right thank you so
much but is that the reason you ended up
going back to college was you got out of
service and you were like maybe I should
finish Maybe what I wanted to do in the
first place is that one of the reasons
so I started college right after high
school and quickly realized that that
wasn't uh what I wanted to do I joined
the army spent 22 years there after gra
after retiring in
2017 uh I decided I was either going
back to work or we were going back to
school Robin wasn't too excited about
the Wii part but she came around and
eventually we ended up at Texas Lutheran
University oh that's incredible so what
I mean Ashley how was that going to
school like with your parents and
graduating with your parents that's
incredibly cool it it was it was really
awesome um they asked me permission
first so they they made sure it was okay
um and I had been in college for a year
and I had nothing but great things to
say about Texas Lutheran University so I
was just so excited to share that
experience with them and to see them
come to a four-year College it was just
so exciting I was just so proud yeah
it's such such a a great thing for just
an inspiration for a lot of people who
want to go back and just feel like well
maybe I miss up the opportunity you know
and you never have you can always go
back so what was graduation day like
first of all I was trying to prepare not
to fall while walking the
stage and so after that I I was able to
turn around and um it was very surreal
watching my husband and um
daughter you know walked the stage after
me yeah it was very touching yeah well
um thank you guys so much this is the
coolest story I don't think I've ever
heard of anything like this happening uh
but grank and Robin I'm liking your post
right now but that's not all our season
long partner pilot pin makers of
friction the go-to rasb pin of the Kelly
Clark and show want to celebrate people
like you fearlessly chasing your dreams
and inspiring everybody in the in the
mean meanwhile um so they're going to
give you $1,000 how's that
sound congratulations to all of you that
is so super cool and thank you to all
our guests this Alex Dion Warwick Damon
Elliott Mikey day Ivan marero Blake and
Logan all have a great ve of it's not
try Chang
[Music]
it
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home